let's talk about Game of Thrones I
wanted to talk about that first right
okay going going off the Breaking Bad uh
Game of Thrones
going off the Breaking Bad Point okay
okay this is definitely going to be a
hot take
I thought season eight was the best what
are you gonna say I prefer the later
seasons of Game of Thrones [ __ ] oh God
genuinely okay genuinely do you know how
bad oh that is I I was tired right we've
been filming all day that woke me the
[ __ ] up guys
I will tell you how bad of a take that
was I haven't seen a single episode of
Game of Thrones and I know that was
wrong that is that is no that's how I
know how much of a bad thing that was
like it's like I want the one written by
uh the people who didn't write read the
book and I want Ed Sheeran in it and I
want to be people who thinks yeah Ed
Sheeran was in an episode like it is it
is just bad
oh my God what do you like about that
what explain yourself okay okay you're
on trial right now okay I'm on trial
right now like I said like I said about
breaking bad it felt like tell me the
season it got good first and then tell
me why
um I mean I mean I think it was always
good okay well it was always good but it
just got when I really when I really got
invested was around season six my
favorite season was about season seven
uh this is season seven the One season
where like all everyone got pissed off
no no that's season eight oh that's
season eight and even even I'm like okay
season eight okay that's that was that
was that was seven that was shocked that
was a little blunder that was a little
blunder right there all right but I I
okay because here's the thing right
going back to my Breaking Bad energy I
know I got the entire world watching me
right now I have got the entire [ __ ]
world watching me right now and then
people will wonder man why is the
subreddit spiking
after this episode
I can understand the Breaking Bad tell
you this one feels irredeemable I can't
wait to read the comments on this
episode go on
like I said Game of Thrones seasons one
to four is almost perfect television
it's [ __ ] fantastic yeah characters
are well written well defined the World
building is amazing and everything like
that
um like I said seasons one to four I
didn't really have any emotional
attachment to it it's literally George
RR Martin's baby at that point that's
he's he did everything at that point no
I no I I agree so how do you how do you
what how do you get more attached when
[ __ ] HBO takes over they're generic
Riders because one thing that I [ __ ]
love one aspect I love in any media is
when you have different kind of
different kind of aspects and cultures
clashing together right that's kind of
like why everybody I'm invested in the
MCU where you have you know Wizards and
superheroes and now you know [ __ ]
Cosmic God people all existing within
the same universe and that's that's kind
of that's because that's what drew me
into Game of Thrones originally and what
I [ __ ] my favorite parts of Game of
Thrones was in the later Seasons when
you finally saw this these different
worlds that have been built up in
seasons one two and three and four and
stuff like that you finally saw all
these worlds kind of colliding in
together and having some really really
cool moments is the writing as good [ __ ]
no okay I will fully admit the writing
is not as good but was it [ __ ] badass
seeing the Dothraki riding over a hill
with a [ __ ] Dragon like [ __ ]
burning the Lannisters hell yeah that
was bad [ __ ] ass and I will like
defend that [ __ ] all right I think it it
it built it up so well and then just
[ __ ] unraveled the coil and then just
threw a bunch of cool battles at us to
distract our pretty little brains I
think it it squandered everything it
built up I I think it was about politics
and then it suddenly became about Ed
Sheeran and shitty battles and just
rushing it no I will totally agree it
was
Seasons you Game of Thrones was two
completely different shows I mean that's
I I fully admit it was two completely
different shows and technically I should
out of like every bone in my body think
that the first four seasons are the
better ones but I'm following my heart
and my heart says you cool dragons for
burning stuff oh look at the dragons
burning the ice zombies isn't that so
cool oh God if you want an easy card
guys
yes okay yes let's get the [ __ ] out of
here with this [ __ ] tape I actually [ __ ]
take when do you okay when do you think
Game of Thrones Go Bad season five
season five yeah season five started
falter what was it what was what
happened in season five again I felt
like season five
I can't remember exactly I do remember
because I had been watching Game of
Thrones weekly since season three season
three was amazing season four was just
[ __ ] god tier yeah one of the most
iconic moments in the series uh just it
was like headies and four season three
season four as well I had the one fight
between the two people oh memorable oh
yeah yeah yeah um I love how he just
fully understood no yeah you know it's
that scene
um I remember that scene actually gave
me PTSD like what yeah how seeing a
character and this happens a lot by the
way but there's there's one particular
scene where you saw a character that you
really liked and you got emotionally
attached to seeing them like get killed
off in such a gruesome way and just
actually gave me like an emotional like
guttural reaction yeah me too yeah and
it was isn't that a good thing though it
was horrible no no no that's why it's
good though yeah I know I know they
managed to get that emotion out of you
yeah I I totally agree it was a
different thing gonna do that yeah I
don't know man I don't know what
characters I'm just like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] do it again yeah and then like
you know end of season three as well
what happened at the end of season three
one of the most famous one of the most
iconic TV moments of all time yes
no you've heard of it you know you have
heard of it yes
don't know anything about it I know you
don't but the only thing I know about
Game of Thrones is it's Lord of the
Rings with tits yeah like like that's
what people have told me like people are
dumb yeah like I said you sold me like I
said perfect television
is a pretty recent one I feel like I've
seen this if you've gone on Netflix
you've seen this yeah yeah yeah it's
pushed it down everyone yeah this is
this is a Netflix show again only four
seasons
um it passes itself off as a comedy but
I don't really think it's a comedy so
the whole premise of the good place is
uh you know the good place is an analogy
for heaven of course okay so all of
these people have died and gone to
heaven
except for Kristen Bell
who is the main character in the good
place uh she wakes up in heaven right
but when they tell her like when I talk
about her life story and identity in
person she was and everything she did on
Earth she realizes that she's up in
heaven by mistake okay and she the whole
premise initially is her trying to
convince everyone that yes she is this
person who they all believe her to be
and she is a good person that belongs in
heaven right uh and that's that's that's
how the premise of the story you know
starts off and honestly
like I the good place started off as a
show that was just you know I just put
on in the background as background noise
I was like this isn't bad but this is
like good enough where I'm like I can
have it on the background just as white
noise to be like oh it's it's all right
it's all right it's it's a I like the
concept of like them going up to heaven
and everything like that it was like a
nice little Chemistry Between all the
characters and everything like that it
was okay
um and then without spoiling what
happens a big twist happens at the end
of the first season
that I like I did not know that it was
going to be that kind of show where it
turned the good place into just like a
kind of like wacky sitcom comedy into
these characters have a motive and
they're going to try to achieve
something and I have an end goal and you
get to see not only the the character
progression but it kind of just becomes
an entire Adventure right like Bojack
right like lulls you in with the funny
animals and just hits you with the
depression yeah yeah exactly but yeah
one one thing I [ __ ] loved about the
good place is one like it is a whole
complete story right when you when you
think of most sitcoms sitcoms don't
really have stories you know what I mean
sitcoms are just okay you know you're
self-contained it's it's kind of like oh
which character's gonna get with which
character oh is Rachel gonna get with
Ross oh Rachel go with Ross by the way
and the friends bye-bye I really hope
that wasn't going to I hope nobody cares
about that spoiler to be fair I was
close to putting friends on them that's
a good show
but the point is there isn't really an
ongoing story yeah this one had comedic
moments right but what it what what
really shines in my eyes is the ongoing
story and within this ongoing story it
tackles so many issues about the
afterlife about religion about morals
and it's one of those shows where you
get you get in on the laughs and you
know you say Bojack was about depression
I was surprised you didn't put Bojack on
by the way I thought I thought someone
would put Bojack yeah I don't know I
didn't you know I feel like everything's
been said about it yeah yeah but like
the good place is one of those shows
where you end and it's just like such a
thing it leaves you with like such a
warm feeling where it feels like
wholesome yeah it's it's it's I've
watched it through osmosis
it's it's not just it's not just
wholesome but it gives you like a good
life message at the end of it and you
feel like damn you know get sort of the
opposite of Bojack the neutral yeah
[Laughter]
there are two sides of the coin yeah
yeah exactly where you know it you you
leave the end of good place and I've
never just like I've never cried over a
leave in a good good place do I believe
in a good place do you leave in a good
place do you leave in a good place well
I won't spoil oh what the ending of good
place is thank you but uh but you know
it's I've I've it's all right yeah it's
rare that I cry over a sitcom okay but
the sick the good place is the only
comedy that's ever made me cry at the
end of it just because seeing these
characters come to the end of their
Journey their adventure and just seeing
how each character story ended was just
so gratifying and I was just genuinely
happy for everyone in the story amazing
[ __ ] shot uh just season one just
wait till the end of season one